[Música]
k
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos um prazer
estar falando com vocês aqui hoje sejam
bem-vindos para mais uma live dos
apoiadores da comunidade fechada é um
prazer est falando com
vocês aparentemente não temos Ninguém ao
vivo agora se tiver alguém escutando Por
favor dê um
alô e eu já vou começar respondendo as
perguntas tá do documento e dessa vez eu
resolvi fazer de um outro jeito que eu
acho que vai ficar mais fácil de
ler desta maneira
aqui eu acho que fica mais fácil pra
leitura por enquanto nós temos cinco
perguntas
aqui deixa eu ver qual que é a melhor
forma de apresentar isso aqui
[Música]
hum ah assim é melhor eu
acho apresentar
assim não temos Ninguém ao vivo
aparentemente não tem ninguém mas vou
começar então a responder ah Boa noite
Estela Mares obrigado por ter
comparecido me dá aí uma posição de como
é que tá o áudio tá me escutando bem
assim que você responder eu já vou
começar a responder as perguntas aqui
Boa noite Kell Kell tá ouvindo bem ok
ótimo Stela obrigado pela posicionamento
Eliseu Boa
noite vamos lá então Caro Dr Alan qual é
o produto de reposição de ideia usado na
medicina
integrativa é basicamente o mesmo ideia
que a gente usa tá de outras fontes tá o
importante a gente ter uma noção de que
essa ideia é de um bom fabricante bom
fornecedor você pode usar na forma de
cápsula pode usar na forma de creme
tópico dá para manipular com o nome
prasterona e geralmente essa ideia vem
de uma planta chamada dioscorea vilosa
então ele é de
estrutura molecular Idêntica ao Deia
humano agora tem que tomar muito cuidado
com Deia porque o Deia geralmente é
utilizado em doses excessivas e mulheres
tá então o que você acha facilmente no
mercado é 25 50 e 100 mg pra mulher a
dose padrão média é 10 mg e para homem é
por volta de 25 então tomem cuidado a
que seja doença autoimune doença
autoimune aí você pode usar doses mais
altas eu tenho uma paciente que tem uma
esclerose múltipla que eu passo para ela
100 mg tá mas aí corre o risco de
virilização de dar pelo no rosto
oleosidade esse risco para ela é
totalmente aceitável porque ela tem uma
doença
autoimune Então mas para uma mulher
normal a dose geralmente a 10 mg tá bom
próxima pergunta é a pergunta do Carlos
na reposição de B12 por injeção Qual a
melhor forma e frequência de
aplicação isso vai variar um pouco viu
Carlos primeiro a gente considerar o
seguinte né as injeções que se acham com
facilidade nas farmácias é de ciano com
balamina né como é o caso por exemplo do
citoneurin o ideal você usar metil
cobalamina ou adenosilcobalamina ou
hidróxi balamina tá a dose pode ser de 1
a 3 MG ou 1000 a 3.000
MG você pode fazer uma ou várias
injeções dependendo da deficiência que
essa pessoa tiver você pode fazer
geralmente entre uma a três injeções uma
vez por semana isso vai depender da
deficiência e da capacidade de absorção
desse paciente se essa paciente por
exemplo tiver uma anemia
perniciosa doses por mais tempo podem
ser necessárias e geralmente a gente faz
intramuscular nessas formas que eu já
comentei evitar aano comob balamina usar
metilcobalamina hidroxil balamina ou
adenosilcobalamina
e monitorar com exames de sangue a
maioria dos pacientes quando você faz só
uma injeção já sobe bastante a B12 ela
mantém alta por volta de três
mes Então seria uma solução pro caso aí
que você tá
descrevendo
que Aliás não foi essa pergunta não mas
tem uma outra pergunta que tava
comentando que a pessoa tava com
dificuldade de absorver pela Via
sublingual próxima pergunta da
Marilda soug
cadas de insetos o senhor poderia
sugerir alguma
estratégia natural para Prevenção ou
tratamento eu acho
que ah tá faltando umas perguntas aqui
vou ter que colocar Tá Mas vamos
lá para alir a picadas de inseto você
tem que tá preocupado realmente utilizar
um repelente natural que tenha
ingredientes atóxicos e eficazes né E
tem então repelentes que são a base de
óleos essenciais o caso do citronela que
é bem eficiente o capim limão o eucalip
são todas opções
seguras E tem também aquela planta da
Medicina Ayurveda na medicina indiana
que é o nim ou neem né Escreve n e e
m a pronúncia é nin óleo de nim é uma
alternativa natural também com
propriedades repelentes
antiinflamatórias Então tem que evitar
os produtos que tem o
deet que podem irritar a pele sensível e
também usar roupas longas usar
coberturas físicas
para evitar pele exposta reaplicar o
repelente isso é chato mas tem que ser
feito a cada duas a 3 horas porque a
duração menor de produtos
químicos e teste pequenas áreas da pele
antes de usar o produto mesmo que seja
natural tá
bom próxima pergunta da
Marilda não sou adepta a vacinas e
também não está mais disponível a vacina
da febre amarela na minha
cidade alguma alternativa para
prevenção bem nesse caso eu recomendo
que você tome a vacina da febre amarela
porque eu tomei essa vacina ano passado
quando eu tive que ir pro
Panamá e eu chequei essa vacina ela não
tem tecnologia nova ela não tem a
tecnologia do RNA mensageiro e tanto eu
quanto minha esposa e as Crianças
tomaram eu tinha tomado vacina de febre
amarela muitos anos atrás aqui no Brasil
mesmo eu não vejo razão de não tomar eu
não conheço uma alternativa
e no sentido de garantir que você não
vai pegar febre amarela Caso seja picada
por o
mosquito e outra coisa vários países
ainda exigem o peru parece que não exige
mais a a vacina de sempre amarela se ele
não exigir e você quiser arriscar entre
aspas você não é obrigado a fazer a
vacina mas acho que não vale a pena
porque essa vacina Ela é bem segura no
meu ponto de vista todo mundo tomou eu
minha esposa as crianças e ninguém teve
reação tá E caso você pegue febre
amarela você pode ficar aí umas duas
semanas de cama com febre alta dor de
cabeça intensa e delícia né com amarelão
nos olhos e pode até se der aar
desenvolver insuficiência hepática ou
renal mas se você fizer questão de não
tomar aí você pode tomar zinco vitamina
C eá que melhora o sistema imune e usar
os repelentes naturais que nós
comentamos aí citronela
né Cap limão comentamos no nim pode ser
também
Andiroba então eu recomendaria
você reconsiderar isso tá
tem uma pergunta da Kelly
aqui o Dea realmente ajuda a aumentar os
níveis de testosterona ajuda mas é uma
coisa variável Kelly tem mulher que vai
converter metade do Deia em testo e
outras não vão tá então é um pouco
assim
eh imprevisível tá é melhor você repor
diretamente testosterona e não ficar
comando que quanto do de vai virar
testosterona Boa noite Carlos Boa noite
Isaac vamos pra próxima
[Música]
pergunta qual é a sua recomendação para
caspa quando shampoos convencionais não
funcionam tem uma coisa natural
interessante que você pode
usar no lugar da esse shampo de caspa tá
Primeiro vamos falar um pouquinho sobre
o que que causa a caspa é por um fungo
chamado malesia esse fungo vive no couro
cabeludo ele se alimenta dos óleos da
cabeça e da resto de pele ele causa
descamação se o shampoo e o vinagre de
maçã não resolver
você pode usar por exemplo óleos
antifungicos óleo essencial de melaleuca
ou titri melaleuca ou tea Tree duas
colheres de óleo de coco com cinco gotas
desse óleo de melaleuca Então pega duas
colheres de óleo de coco põe cinco gotas
do óleo de
melaleuca aplica no couro cabeludo faz a
massagem Suave deixa agir por 30 minutos
antes de lavar tanto o óleo de coco
quanto o t leuca vão ter ação
antifungica você também pode colocar
limão diluir um suco de limão uma colher
de sopa em 1 l de água morna use como
enxague
final o ácido cítrico vai ajudar a
equilibrar o PH do couro cabeludo tá
então você pode fazer isso em sequência
né Fazer o uso do óleo antifungico e
depois lavagem com
limão Você também pode fazer chá
medicinal preparar um chá de lã Pimenta
ou peppermint né duas colheres de folhas
em 1 l de água e uso como inago e também
após a lavagem do cabelo
[Música]
tá a hortelã tem ação antibacteriana e
antiinflamatória antimicrobiana de modo
geral né e fazer uma dieta baixa em
açúcar cortando açúcar e laticínios que
podem alimentar o
fungo utilizar alimentos e cozinha
ômega-3 como salmão como peixes de águas
geladas Profundas semen chia para
reduzir a inflamação e usar vitaminad e
probióticos também pode est
ajudando
Beleza agora tem mais perguntas aqui mas
deixa eu voltar ao
documento não sei porque que não incluiu
as outras perguntas deixa eu incluir
agora aqui ó em tempo
real só um minuto
tem mais duas perguntas
aqui deixa eu
acrescentar para ficar mais visível isso
aqui
bem vamos
apresentar E
vamos dividir
aqui próxima
pergunta qual a melhor estratégia de
detoxificação natural do corpo para se
tomar quando temos uma deficiência na
defesa antioxidante com polimorfismo da
só do e só de TR são super superóxido de
mutase Alelo de risco acentuado seria
estimular uma outra via de detoxificação
a do nrf2 com sulforafano com enzima
que1 cúrcuma igal C tequino galato os
nas lojas tem um suplemento Sódio tem
sim tem dois suplementos sódio esse
glisodin e tem o sódi Max além desse
glisodin tem o só de Max resolveria o
problema com apenas um suplemento ou
seria melhor utilizar os outros
nutraceuticos mais conhecidos Qual
decisão o senhor tomaria eu Fari uma
combinação
tá eu faria uma combinação
então o que que
estimula que que é ativador da da Via
nrf2 né seria sulforafano
que tem no brócolis que tem no vegetais
crucíferos o sulforafano vai ativar a
produção de enzimas antioxidantes como
glutationa e também em pessoas normais
estimula o sódi no caso quem tem a
mutação vai ter menos no sódio Mas pode
também tá ajudando né porque o
polimorfismo quer dizer que não produz
nada da superóxidos mutadas quer dizer
só que tem uma superóxido mutase menos
eficiente a cúrcuma que você
comentou ajudaria ep galática at aqui no
galato também que você comentou a coz
K10 tudo isso
ajudaria o glisodin e o só
Max ajudar mas como são enzimas exógenas
né que vem do melão a absorção
intestinal não é tão boa assim né Então
teria um problema de absorção intestinal
e de
biodisponibilidade Então pode ajudar mas
eh Pode ser que fique caro porque teria
que tá tomando doses altas para poder
compensar a falta do só de
endógeno então basicamente você falou aí
tá
usar todas essas estratégias e também
utilizar o gliz Odin só de Max eu faria
essa combinação
aí e assim só lembrando uma coisa sofora
Fan ele vai est muito mais concentrado
no bruto de brócolis tá no brócoli
sprout inglês Então procura comprar o
suplemento de brócoli sprout eu nunca
visto no Brasil acho que tem mas tem na
Amazon tem nos Estados Unidos ou compra
o sufor afano Como ativo na farmácia
manipulação
tá próxima pergunta o cogumelo
Reich desempenha algum benefício a nível
cerebral
sim representa
Sim ele é conhecido por suas
propriedades adaptogênico
é utilizado em vários blends de
cogumelos aí que melhoram o
funcionamento cerebral e tem uma
combinação que usa três cogumelos
diferentes e o ganoderma o Reich é um
deles
tá então ele tem propriedades
adaptogênico
ser nervoso central ele ajuda a melhorar
a função cerebral porque ele reduz o
stress
oxidativo ele também melhora os
neurotransmissores como serotonina
dopamina ajuda a regular o humor e
ansiedade e melhora a circulação
sanguínea do
cérebro Então esse produto chama Mr
Complex deixa eu até abrir aqui
o a página dele ele tem uns três
cogumelos
aqui tem algum tempo que eu não
utilizao esse produto mas ele é
[Música]
interessante mostrar aqui para vocês ó
ele é uma combinação esse Mr Complex
deixa eu dividir a tela aqui com vocês
aqui
tá esse ativo já usei várias vezes mas
ultimamente eu não tenho utilizado então
ele é a combinação do cors militares do
ganoderma lúcido que é o Reich e o
coriolus versicolo que o trucky tail
né então ele dá suporte imune energético
longevidade defesa di
área R rico e betaglucanos que são
polissacarídeos imunomoduladores
então lembrei desse produto aqui porque
você comentou do Reich
né Muito bem deixa eu ver se tem mais
alguma pergunta que ficou para trás não
Essa foi a última pergunta vamos ver as
perguntas ao vivo
não o que eu falei naquele vídeo é que
não tem dose tóxica conhecida de silício
orgânico né É isso que eu quis dizer não
é que eu não sabia qual que era a dose
tóxica e que sa continua a mesma coisa
el eu não tem dose tóxica conhecida
porque ele é muito seguro
tá testosterona B Idêntica já é vendido
há muitos anos em farmácia você tá
falando farmácia comum é isso mesmo na
farmácia comum mas na farmácia comum é a
dose é para homem então não recomendo
você comprar para utilizar
e questão de ser uma uma uma dose
apropriada para para
homens sim ajudar a cicatrizar ferida
sim Eliseu
o silício
orgânico sim é verdade o Agri é uma
fonte de silício importante
tá bem aí tem uns artigos que eu queria
falar com vocês que eu separei
aqui a gente estava falando aí de sfan
do brócolis né então tem um artigo
interessante que fala como é que o
brócolis a couve couve flor e repolho
que são os braceras ou crucíferos né
poderiam influenciar a redução do risco
de câncer Então teve um estudo que
analisou mais de 5,7 milhões de pessoas
em 226 estudos observacionais para
entender como é que esses alimentos
poderiam ajudar na prevenção de diversas
formas de câncer
Então os pesquisadores se propuseram a
investigar a associação entre a ingestão
de vegetais crucíferos e o risco global
de câncer além dos riscos individuais
para tipos específicos como pulmão
bexiga próstata trato gastrointestinal
superior então A análise concluiu
estudos desculpa incluiu estudos
realizados em diferentes regiões do
mundo do Japão a Europa e também os
Estados Unidos e a duração das pesquisas
variou entre 2 e 15 anos então foi
apanhado de muitos estudos uma ampla
coleta de dados que ajudou a captar uma
diversidade de os alimentares e
contextos culturais Então os resultados
mostraram que o consumo dos crucíferos
ou braceras como é o caso do cov flou
cov de Bruxelas brócolis está associado
a uma redução no risco de desenvolver
câncer então estudos do tipo cort que
são os considerados de desenho mais
robusto foi observada uma redução de 5%
no risco de câncer de pulmão 13% para
câncer de bexiga e 15% para câncer do
trato gastrointestinal superior n
incluindo o estômago esôfago já nos
estudos do tipo caso controle a chance
de desenvolver o câncer de estômago e
glioma que é um câncer cerebral diminuir
em torno de 20 e 18% de forma respectiva
Então essa variação nos resultados
ressalta que os benefícios podem
depender tanto do tipo do Câncer quanto
do método de estudo utilizado então Além
disso o estudo destacou diferenças
regionais interessantes em populações
asiáticas a ingestão de vegetais
crucíferos estava mais associado à
redução dos riscos de câncer de pulmão e
esôfago Possivelmente devido aos métodos
tradicionais que eles têm que preparar
que preserva os compostos bioativos pro
do outro lado em populações Americanas
os efeitos protetores foram mais fortes
para câncer coloretal e de rim sugerindo
Que fatores genéticos hábitos de vida e
modos de preparo também influenciam
nessa
relação então esses achados reforça a
ideia de que a alimentação e o contexto
cultural caminham lado a lado na
prevenção do câncer Então vamos falar
aqui dos compostos bioativos que estão
presentes nos vegetais cruc são os
glucosinolatos
glucosinolatos flavonoides carotenoides
e vitamina cik então quando eles são
consumidos os glucosinolatos se
transformam em isotiocianatos como é o
caso do sulforafano e os indóis né o
famoso indol indol tres carbinol né que
a gente usa muito para prevenção de
câncer de mama então ess compostos vão
ajudar a reduzir o estess oxidativo vão
ativar enzimas de detox como é o caso lá
que ele falou na pergunta né o
nrf2
nrf2 e também promover a reparação do
DNA então esses mecanismos podem
explicar em parte porque que o consumo
regular de quatro a sete porções por
semana das crucíferas estaria associado
a uma menor incidência de vários tipos
de
câncer então eles não rankear qual dos
vegetais seria o melhor mas os estudos
sugerem que opções como brócolis cve de
Bruxelas cve cve e Flor são todos cores
excelentes são todos cores excelentes
Para incorporar na
dieta Então vale muito a pena tem aquela
conversa que correu na internet por
vários anos falando que se você comer
brócoli você vai ter problema de
tireoide Isso aí foi muito Exagerado
você tem que comer uma quantidade
exageradamente alta de brócolis para dar
problema na tireoide Então vale a pena
comer umas três vezes por semana esses
vegetais crucífero
e é importante preparar esse vegetar de
uma maneira que Preserve os nutrientes
então cozinhar levemente no vapor seria
uma boa
ideia e se você tiver acesso ao broto de
brócolis que eu falei na pergunta
anterior melhor ainda porque tem mais
sufor fana
ainda Então coloque crucíferos na sua
dieta o segundo artigo queria discutir
com vocês é um estudo inovador que
investigou o uso da creatina que vocês
conhecem para musculação para atividade
física e eu já comentei em vídeos
anteriores que também funcionava para
cérebro mas esse estudo investigou a
creatina para melhorar o sintomas de
depressão Então vale a pena se você
tiver depressão experimentar o uso da
creatina porque ela pode ajudar bastante
Nesse contexto Especialmente quando
associado a terapia cognitivo
comportamental Então nesse estudo
randomizado controlado os pesquisadores
queriam saber se a suplementação diária
com 5 g de creatina monoidratada se ela
poderia melhorar os sintomas de
depressão em adultos diagnosticados com
transtorno depressivo maior então para
medir os sintomas foi utilizado numa
escala o patient Health questioner 9 que
é amplamente reconhecido para avaliar a
gravidade da depressão o estudo contou
com 100 participantes idade média de 30
anos que eram divididos igualmente entre
homens e mulheres Eram todos
provenientes da Índia e com níveis de
depressão que variavam de leve a grave
então é importante destacar que os
participantes não haviam utilizado
medicamentos psicotrópicos nas oito
semanas anteriores ao início da pesquisa
então eles fizeram washal ou seja eles
não tomaram remédios por oito semanas
até o início da pesquisa então ao longo
de oito semanas os participantes foram
divididos em dois grupos um grupo
recebeu a suplementação com creatina de
forma diária e contra o outro de
controle tomou Placebo ou seja pílula de
farinha e todos passaram por cinco
sessões de terapia cognitiva
comportamental de 45 minutos cada Então
essa abordagem permitiu aos
pesquisadores avaliar de forma rigorosa
o impacto do suplemento em um cenário de
tratamento psicológico comparando os
resultados entre os dois grupos então um
grupo fez só terapia cognitiva outra fez
cognitiva mais o uso da creatina Ok
porque o grupo que tava tomando Placebo
não sabia que estava tomando Placebo mas
os dois grupos fizeram terapia cognitivo
comportamental e os resultados foram
promissores embora ambos os grupos
tenham apresentado melhoras né porque
ess dois grupos fizeram terapia
cognitiva
comportamental apenas aquele grupo que
recebeu a creatina teve uma melhora
significativamente superior apesar dos
dois grupos terem melhorado então a
diferença não foi apenas estatística mas
também clinicamente relevante Ou seja a
maioria dos participantes do grupo de
creatina teve uma melhora que na prática
Faria toda a diferença no dia a dia
dessas pessoas vamos entender um
pouquinho o contexto por trás da
creatina como é que a gente obtém esse
composto
na alimentação ele vem através de
alimentos como carne vermelha e
peixe ele pode também ser sintetizado
pelo nosso organismo pelo fígado pelos
rins e pelo cérebro a creatina ela
funciona comoção uma bateria ela
desempenha um papel crucial na produção
de energia ela serve como acúmulo de
energia de ATP ela armazena grupos
fosfato de Alta Energia que são
essenciais para regeneração da ATP então
funciona com uma bateria ATP tá falando
uma linguagem bem
simples que vocês sabem que é a
principal fonte de energia das células
Então como o cérebro depende
constantemente dessa energia para
funcionar de forma ideal manter bons
níveis de creatina é importante é
fundamental paraa saúde
cerebral além disso a creatina tem se
mostrado capaz de aumentar o conteúdo no
próprio cérebro quando é suplementado o
que pode ajudar dá melhorar a função
neuronal então pesquisas pré-clínicas
sugerem que ela atua modulando os
receptores de neurotransmissores ela vai
ativar por exemplo os receptores de
dopamina e serotonina no cérebro
enquanto isso vai inibir os receptores
nmda que é de
glutamato além de reduzir o stress
oxidativo e aumentar os níveis de bdnf
né Brain derived neurotropic Factor que
é um fator neurotrófico importante e
sobrevivência dos neurônios então esses
mecanismos fornecem uma explicação
plausível pros efeitos antidepressivos
ele modula neurotransmissor aumenta a
energia e reduz o estresse
oxidativo além de aumentar o
bdnf O que torna Esse estudo
interessante que ele foi realizado com
participantes que não estavam tomando
antidepressivos diferente de outros
estudos que já exploraram a creatina
como um complemento aos medicamentos
tradicionais então esse aqui usou eles
isolados né a creatina
isolada havia já pesquisas anteriores
que tinham apontado que a creatina
melhorava sintomas de depressão em
modelos animais e ensaios clínicos em
pessoas que já estavam tomando
antidepressivo mas esse estudo ele
reforça a ideia de que mesmo
isoladamente sem o uso concomitante de
antidepressivos a suplementação com
creatina é válida em interessante pode
trazer benefícios interessantes quando
associado a intervenções psicológicas
como é o caso do TCC terapia cognitivo
comportamental então a creatina pode ser
uma ferramenta valiosa no Arenal contra
a depressão já tem um
efeito de melhora cognitiva Então vale
muito a pena
utilizar e devemos ter mais estudos do
Futuro mando isso
daí beleza vamos ver se tem mais
perguntas ao
vivo Existe algum jeito específico de
consumir o tempero folhas de louro para
fins cicatrização consumir do jeito
habitual elizu não tem um jeito especial
não carboidrato dificulta se for açúcar
ou alimento processado e industrializado
pode inflamar o organismo e dificultar
cicatrização agora se for um carboidrato
natural como se fosse uma batata doce
uma mandioca não Não vai
atrapalhar a partir de quantos nanogram
por decilitro de D3 a depressão entra em
remissão não não é assim não Eliseu não
tenho essa informação direta não a
vitamina D ajuda a prevenir e a tratar
depressão mas não é não existe na
literatura que eu saiba um nível exato
para todo mundo que vai ter esse efeito
antidepressivo não tá
bom deixa eu ver se eu pulei alguma
pergunta
aqui não não pulei
não mais perguntas pessoal
eu vou ter uma re reunião daqui a
pouquinho acho que eu vou encerrar mais
cedo hoje
tá vocês TM algum comentário sobre os
artigos que nós discutimos hoje vocês
têm interesse de que discuta algum tipo
específico de artigo porque eu tô
pegando isso da do serviço de assinatura
que eu tenho sobre artigos de nutrição
tá então são as coisas que estão saindo
mais recentes aí do mundo
acadêmico mas às vezes você tem alguma
algum interesse algum assunto específico
a gente pode também est abordando aí nas
lives futuras
obrigada mas Estela
pela suu posicionamento aí muito
obrigado pela
gentileza eu tento trazer coisas
relevantes para vocês né
artigos que fazem alguma
diferença e que são dessa área de
nutrição especialmente
né Bem pessoal acho que eu vou encerrar
por aqui não Eliseu tá falando aqui uma
coisa artigo sobre alimentação para
aceleração de cicatrização de feridas
que passaram por
sutura vamos ver se eu acho alguma coisa
a respeito viu
Eliseu F até dar uma olhada
aqui deixa eu ver que a gente acha
alguma coisa
Tô fazendo uma busca aqui com o modelo
novo o TR
mini Vê se acha alguma
coisa mas como ele pensa ele raciocina
demora um pouquinho
aqui tá falando uma série de nutrientes
na pesquisa mas ele não tá mencionando o
artigo exatamente qual que é o
artigo que ele tá acessando
não tô achando a fonte exata disso
aqui bem que tá falando sobre consumir
proteína de forma suficiente vitamina C
zinco né que você sabe que é importante
para sistema imune vitamina
A omega3
ferro vitamina e
arginina que é o aminoácido que é ajuda
na síntese de
colágeno e
hidratação bem depois eu vejo com mais
calma sobre
isso sim sim é eu não fiz uma um vídeo
especificamente sobre isso não
Carlos tá falando aqui mas tem interesse
no funcionamento das enzimas app e de e
temal eu fiz um vídeo sobre temal vários
anos atrás viu
Carlos dá uma olhada lá no canal você
vai achar o vídeo que eu falei sobre tma
e
tmao agora app né que é do Alzheimer né
ide Não nunca fiz vídeo sobre isso
não bem pessoal vou dar depois uma
olhada nessa história de cicatrização E
posso trazer alguma coisa para vocês aí
tá bom agradeço vocês terem comparecido
a nossa Live um grande abraço para vocês
um beijo no coração até a próxima